no I'm manager of this store i'm
wondering what you're doing oh I'm just
starting a conversation about rice okay
um you don't work in you can't actually
do that here in problem I'm not working
here I'm just standing on aI don't want
you doing them from my store well we're
just starting a conversation about race
when we talk to you about race laughs at
starbucks we think racism is a bit of a
grande problem so we're trying to make
it more of a toll problem and are you
interested in helping starbucks make it
a toll problem good what's your favorite
race my favorite racing we're Hispanic
so we'll go from Hispanic the human race
think everybody it's my favorite
Americans are fools I say the marathon
it's a good competition and started over
in Greece so that's right said do you
think HBO's girls was to what I think
they need an Asian guy like me on the
show for sure they'll be funny how many
shots are in the Ferguson espresso come
the Charter than a Ferguson is breath
there too well actually it's 60 are ya
six yeah it's guess yeah yeah probably
full more than needed how do you think
starbucks can fix racism don't serve
black maybe they could just serve
african-american oh yeah have you tried
our new flat white privilege no I have
it it's great it's not served in a cup
it's served in a smug wow she try it
yeah you'd really like coffee man I'm
gonna pull out some race-based
conversation starters all right and I
want you to you'd pick one that you like
did you have a childhood friend of a
different race that you lost touch with
why that's a good one I go in there I
tell them that I'm doing out yeah all
right follow me back so Kevin enters the
starbucks coffee shop armed with a
starbucks talking point but will he end
racism forever
can I ask you a question verse like I
have an answer did you have a childhood
friend of a different race that you lost
touch with and why yeah and move to move
I move you move I moved out of the city
with into the same county but uh okay in
20 different schools and haven't talked
to him since oh me too oh wow what race
was he or you know I don't know you
don't know it was like a mexican asian
mix oh cool and you're yourself am i
your mind up any spanish irish Naraku a
mutt tuber California hi Bert right on
and he did it Kevin ended racism so keV
how was that to be honest the barista
was really nice and he had some really
question maybe this thing works it's
like that Michael Jackson song black or
white that's actually how I prefer my
coffee black or white it doesn't matter
if my coffee is like oh I did that's
music watching Kevin made me realize
that maybe starbucks was right maybe
they went through the grinder for
nothing maybe this campaign actually
does work and maybe we are the ones that
need to race together together
you